some might call it romantic but behind  the scenes  this moment between bella and wolf jacob  feels very awkward  lautner behaved as the wolf for the sake  of eye lines and getting the right  motivation  meanwhile lautner in a full gray onesie  bent his head down for stewart to pat  renesme cullen gave us super creepy  uncanny valley vibes  it was so bad the crew nicknamed it  chuck esme  the doll was a nightmare on set and  screen so the team opted for real  children with cgi instead  kristen stewart's doll double was  perfectly creepy  she was brought to life to make the  near-death scene look as realistic as  possible  the doll was then amplified even further  with cgi  we're not sure what looks stranger the  final cut or behind the scenes